all right george yes george where are
you from originally where did you grow
up i was born in brooklyn
i lived in brooklyn until i was almost
14
and then my parents moved to this
neighborhood
in manhattan and i have had the same
apartment since 1951. wow
how would you describe your childhood
you had mom and dad yes i'm an only
child
and my parents were
very
nice reasonable wonderful people
and they had a
machine shop where they made precision
metal products for airplanes for
propellers i guess they're no more
propellers
and they were hoping i'd go into their
business and when i started college i
studied engineering but i more or less
hated it
and i didn't know there was such a
subject as linguistics
so i
eventually switched to majoring in
french and then in graduate school i
discovered the word linguistics and went
into linguistics in utah
and i taught
i taught linguistics mostly at the
college of staten island city university
but they also had a faculty exchange
agreement with her bay university in bao
ding china neither of which i had ever
heard of
and i went there and taught two separate
spring semesters 1984 and 1989. so
you're teaching
foreign students how to speak how to
speak english but i was also teaching
the english majors linguistics it was a
requirement if you were an english major
to take linguistics which was taught in
chinese
but since there was a faculty exchange
agreement one of their teachers had come
to staten island met me took two courses
with me in staten island went back to
uh bauding
and suggested that they hire me and that
the link was that the english majors
rather than taking the regular english
course which is taught in chinese should
take it in english taught by a native
speaker of english
in particular by his former teacher you
speak beautifully by the way oh thank
you and uh what's your view on how
americans are speaking english today
well about lots has changed a lot of
slang a lot of stuff has changed people
always put in the word like
which they never used to do
and that's a change and then
now some parts of the country made a
distinction between the words cut and
caught c-o-t and c-a-u-g-h-t
and some didn't and this distinction is
disappearing
so my grandson who lives in an apartment
in the same building where i live
uh says
things like i caught cold sleeping in
the cot
which is very different from what new
yorkers ordinarily say
yeah there's a lot of other slang things
that have become part of the
yeah but i really hear people saying
like all the time
and uh
you know i remember once years and years
ago before it was that common being sort
of startled when there were passers-by
and
a woman was saying
she was like oh my god and i was like
and i thought
what an interesting construction yeah i
think a lot of that came from the
california
that's very likely yeah and
then i've heard people doing it
who were not speaking english or not
speaking standard english
so one day i was in washington square
and there was a black woman
and she began her sentence with like she
said
like ain't nobody don't do that [ __ ]
one of it was one of the most
interesting people i've ever met here in
new york was a cab driver who picked me
up at jfk wants to take me to the city
and it was a
chinese man
who i expected didn't speak any english
because he looked like he was right off
the boat from china
except he talked like this he was from
he grew up in an all-italian
neighborhood he spoke exactly like
vinnie and
joey from the neighborhood one finds
these things out sure it's part of the
variety of new york it's fascinating but
then a few minutes after i heard that
woman say that there was another woman
passing by speaking on the telephone in
italian
and she said
like
and i thought that was really
interesting
what how has new york city changed in
all your years you're you're old i am
84. 84 and you lived here for most of
your life pretty much all my life except
two half years in uh china and two years
in philadelphia
and also my parents had a farm upstate
new york but i never lived there year
round
but we spend summers and weekends there
how has new york city changed over the
decades
i think it has become
it feels safer maybe not right away not
right now but mostly i feel it has grown
safer
and
more expensive and more luxurious and
generally nicer
yeah i've been coming here since
like 1990
and i
the variety of like the grocery stores
have improved tremendously drug stores
all that stuff
it was it's come light years from where
it was then yes i really think it's
wonderful it's filled with variety
although now because of the covid
things have shut down we were talking
about how it used to be a 24-hour city
and now it's not less so yeah
and uh you you were married i have been
married for 59 years oh you're still
married your wife is around yes my wife
is around
and i have two daughters one of whom
gave me these pants
those are unforgettable yes and uh and
the other one
and my grandson have an apartment in the
same building where i live those are the
families all yes and my older daughter
who gave me the
pants lives two blocks north of me
that's nice so the frozen north family
is a family is a great thing to keep
intact it is wonderful it's really
wonderful what what have you learned in
your 84 years what's what's important to
you
what do people maybe miss out on
in their lives uh
that's important one thing i feel i
learned is
it's no fun being angry
you should try very hard not to be angry
and calm down and if somebody's done
something wrong well so what
exactly and another thing i feel i've
learned is you never can entirely
understand how another person feels we
we sense the world differently
uh for
one peculiar example
when i was younger i could hear very
high pitches i could hear dog whistles
and i can still hear high pitches but i
can no longer hear dog whistles but i
mean that's just one example of how
people are different from each other we
taste things differently some people are
green blind or red-blind most are not
but i mean it's part of the difference
but there are all sorts of little
differences that we don't know how to
talk about yeah one person's childhood
can be very very different from others
and that changes your perception of it
it certainly does yeah
and your childhood was great sounds like
it was pretty much great uh
i was really
very happy with my parents although i
didn't like being an engineering major
in college but that was not too long
that was for about two years or two and
a half years
till
uh
i very fortunately flunked physics i was
happy that that happened
do you have any regrets in your in your
life
well there were times when i said things
to people that weren't kind and i'm
sorry i did that
one peculiar example i was a child and
didn't quite know better but
uh
i
had an and much older than my uh parents
and she took care of her in-laws who
were very very very old
and it was a real
task for her it was very it was hard
work
and they died within about a month of
each other at the ages of i think 99 and
97
and my parents and i went to make a
condolence call and i said to her oh you
must be very happy
and my parents said no no she's not
happy and i said oh i know
but i guess i wasn't aware of the fact
that i was saying the wrong thing yeah
you seem very happy
mostly
has most of your life been
it's been mostly pretty good pretty good
i've had some difficult experiences i
left china the day after the tiananmen
massacre
the massacre was june 4th 1989
um
the university where i was teaching
drove me and my daughter to the
beijing airport the next day june 5th
and then we flew to tokyo where we had
not made any plans to visit
and so i discovered that tokyo has the
best pizza in the world
really
well yes maybe i thought so because i
had just run away from china
but i think it really did
that's funny
do you believe in uh
in luck
well there's all sorts of things that
are lucky and unexpected some people
just have
seemed to escape death over and over and
over and then other ones tragically die
yes
these things really do happen and
sometimes something happens and you
think it's bad luck but it turns out to
be good life absolutely that's what i've
seen
i very briefly had a job teaching at nyu
my immediate superior was an
extraordinarily nasty guy
and i knew i wouldn't be rehired
and at the end of the
fall semester i quit the job and decided
to spend the whole spring semester
full time working on my dissertation
although this was economically a problem
but anyway i
i made that decision and i finished my
dissertation
my advisor approved it set a date for
defense of the dissertation and died ten
days before my defense
and you know if
if if he hadn't already set a date i'd
have had a new advisor who would have
looked at it and said well maybe we can
salvage it
and
so i was so lucky that i
had gotten had this miserable guy at nyu
who made me want to quit the job
and
it made me finish my dissertation while
my advisor was still alive he died at
the age of 41.
well
older generations always seem to
disapprove of how the younger
generations are
just operating and functioning in the
world what what do you think of younger
kids now you see a lot of them at
washington square park where we met well
i feel
mostly they're very pleasant and nice
and interesting and
on the other hand
i think
a lot of kids don't appreciate the fact
that the united states is a democratic
country and that there's freedom of
speech
and of course i've lived in china and
very much became aware of the fact that
there was no freedom of speech in china
but uh
i i am
a little surprised that there is
not much feeling of respect for
democracy yeah
yeah a lot of people just seem unhappy
with everything about the united states
well and then now we have
all sorts of extremists running around
so that's
i mean i think they have the right to
run around because i believe in freedom
but they seem to be coming
they are becoming increasingly dominant
yeah
a lot of these extremist groups
voicing opinions right
well once there was a guy giving a talk
in washington square standing on a
soapbox and saying
there is no freedom of speech in the
united states
and i said to him you won't believe me
but if you lived in the united states
you could say that and nothing would
happen to you
and he said i don't understand i do live
in the united states
and i said and you just said that and
you weren't afraid to say it and you
haven't been arrested and he said
america is racist so that was his way of
changing the subject
do you feel like the older generations
like your generation
understood hard work
and delayed gratification more than
these younger kids do
that's a hard question i'm not sure i
didn't
oh yeah
you told me on the way here that you
like to be lazy yes yes no i never
really liked hard work that much
and uh
and when uh
well
when i was a child i didn't eat potatoes
and some of my aunts and uncles said to
my parents if you don't make me him eat
potatoes he'll grow up to be a bum
and then when i became a professor one
of my uncles said see
so
he felt being a professor was being a
bum
and of course you don't quite do any
hard work
once on our farm
my mother and i
were trying to shovel out a cesspool for
some reason to make some repair i can't
remember what the situation was
and it was too much for us
and we
saw the grandson of the neighboring
farmer his name was arnold and we asked
if he could do it and arnold could dig
much much better than my mother and me
put together
and after the job was finished then we
paid arnold my mother said what a
wonderful young man if only you could be
like arnold
and i said
if you dig you get paid the minimum wage
and my mother said what's money if you
can dig like that
and sometimes my mother was very witty
what was your favorite your favorite
decade
of your life
oh such a hard question
um
possibly
the
80s when i which included my living in
china even though it included some scary
experiences
but it's hard to know a lot of people
were making good money in the 80s
i was always i
always made sufficient money
i mean you know you don't get rich if
you're a professor but
but i always had a reasonably
satisfactory salary and i did have
tenure which is very wonderful that's
great
what was what's your favorite thing and
least favorite thing about new york city
uh
my favorite thing is
the
variety
and the openness
and my least favorite thing i think is
the noise at night
excellent but
it's okay i i've gotten to deal with it
yeah it's part of new york city right
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
possibly to be tolerant of other people
and to feel you'll never fully
understand them
and somehow i taught myself not to get
angry and i think that's i don't know
how that happened but it did happen it's
a great one
all right george thank you so much for
sharing your story oh thank you thank
you i wish you the best of luck and you
too
you